youri gagarine un symbole de la conquête
de l'espace par l'homme fils d'un
charpentier et d'une paysanne ayant subi
l'occupation nazie il est formé comme
ouvrier métallurgiste puis devient
pilote de chasse en 1959 il intègre le
programme de sélection des cosmonautes
du programme spatial soviétique et en
1961 est désigné pour tenter le premier
vol humain dans l'espace le 12 avril la
fusée vostok 1 se détache du cosmodrome
de baïkonour au kazakhstan
108 minutes de vol en effectuant une
orbite autour de la terre
érigé en héros de l'union soviétique
il meurt tragiquement lors d'un vol
d'entraînement à bord de son avion de
chasse
à seulement 34 ans chaque 12 avril la
russie fait ce vol mythique et 60 ans
après youri gagarine reste toujours
aussi populaire